we are getting some more details tonight
about the fatal crash that happened in
trump nsp says three of the five
passengers traveling on u.s 95 were
killed right near state route 373 in
amargosa valley christian casares
joining us live outside of umc where two
survivors from that crash were later
taken christian
well brian i can tell you that a woman
was airlifted and a juvenile was driven
here to the hospital after yesterday's
fatal crash with non-life-threatening
injuries i can also tell you that nye
county sheriff has identified tonight
the three victims as 41-year-old thomas
katan 12-year-old abiel katan and
seven-year-old ayana kattan as for the
survivors here at the hospital the nsp
tells us both are expected to survive
tonight christos verochnose is at nye
county detention center after he was
arrested at the scene of this fatal
accident nevada state police say this
collision on u.s 95 at mile marker 27
near amargosa valley happened around 11
30 sunday morning preliminary details
show verocnos was driving northbound in
this silver volvo and failed to stay
within his travel lane as he crossed
into oncoming traffic the volvo
sideswiped a truck towing a camper and
hit a gmc yukon it smashed into a gray
chrysler minivan where three of the five
passengers inside were killed according
to nsp including two juveniles a dog
traveling with rock nose was also killed
this crash did have u.s 95 between state
route 160 and 373 closed for hours
wolverachnos is currently at the knight
county detention center where he faces
more than uh
10 charges 11 charges to be exact
including three counts of dui causing
death and resisting an officer christian
cassette is live local now